here's what we know though if it is her
then i think the situation is going to
play out the way that i've just
described that democrats are going to so
overreach on this
it's going to turn off a lot of people
democrats might still win the election
because they might steal it in the mail
but
it's going to be kavanaugh part two
except amy coney barrett is even more
sympathetic than
brett kavanaugh this milk toast lawyer
what we're seeing happen
was just expressed in a viral video
and i think this viral video is the
perfect symbol
for how the democrats are conducting
themselves on the national level
a woman is driving her car she sees some
trump supporters rallying on the side
and she starts screaming at them and she
starts flipping them off and she starts
becoming very very upset and then
as she's screaming she crashes into the
car in front of her
[Music]
there she is screaming if you up and
there's the fender bender
up whoopsie daisy and then the
the trump because the she's screaming at
them flipping them off from people like
hey hey lady how you doing
then she crashes into the car and
obviously they start laughing
and start joking about it
then you hear the cops pull up no
you're not telling me there happened to
be cops there and then the cops walk up
to her and say sorry lady that's what
the democrats are doing
they are screaming and yelling and
they're so
full of rage that
they're allowing themselves to crash
their car they're crashing their car
right into the people in front of
causing damage and getting themselves in
a whole lot of trouble
well when your normal person is looking
at that
which side are they going to turn to all
great news if even my man mitt
is going to go toward the trump side now
where does the rest of the country stand
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you